meanwhile the left continues to push its
radical woke agenda but Arkansas
governor Sarah hgab Sanders she's
fighting back as she is now set to sign
an executive order Banning woke
anti-women words from state government
use she joins us now with more great to
have you Governor how are
you I'm doing great thanks for having me
on tonight Sean all right let's talk
about that then I want to get your
reaction to the president
tonight yeah the idea that we have this
just Absol Insanity we are now living in
a world where everything is crazy versus
what's normal and the left continues to
push this woke agenda basically trying
to erase the differences of women versus
men ignoring all of Science and biology
and completely ignoring the fact that
women have a unique perspective only
women can actually give birth no matter
how many different ways they say it that
fact is completely based in science and
real reality and we are no longer going
to allow them to redefine terms that
weaken and frankly demean women here in
state government documents and here in
the state of Arkansas let's talk about
the issue of where we are in Immigration
last week reports 19 Iranians were
discovered at our border 17 syrians um
Governor I got to imagine that with the
the president of the United States
aiding and embedding what will be at the
end of this year 8 million illegal
immigrants into this country and giving
them free transportation and according
to the Congressional report 99% once
they get in they stay they're not going
anywhere and we've got people on the
terror watch list that they caught I
worry about how many they didn't catch
and I I've just got to wonder you as a
governor how you feel about the fact
that in all likelihood terrorists people
that have terrorist sympathies have
gotten into this country and terrorist
cells exist and there's been no vetting
of any of these people what do we do
about
that well not only as a governor but as
an American citizen I'm frustrated and I
think everybody else should be too
because this is the exact type of policy
that this Administration has allowed to
not only weaken our country but also
embolden our enemies the reason that we
are seeing things around the world where
we are fighting two different Wars are
because the disastrous policies of this
Administration whether it was empowering
Iran whether it's weakening our own
border the disastrous withdrawal from
Afghanistan every single area that they
engage in they either fail or weaken the
strength of our country and we cannot
allow them to continue pushing these
disastrous policies that not only hurt
our country but hurt our allies we are
seeing Governors across the country step
up and try to fight back against some of
these outrageous policies including at
the border because what they have
allowed to take place is an absolute
travesty and it's I think just one of
the many examples where this
Administration has failed the American
people and allowed their recklessness
not only to weaken us at home but
certainly abroad as we're seeing unfold
over the last several days and even
months of the situation going on in
Ukraine all right Governor Sarah Sanders
you're doing a great job down there in
Arkansas happy about the fact that you
you won that race by a huge margin
congratulations hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else